what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's been a while but today we have
some news about the Young Avengers
making their way to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now we have been talking about
the Young Avengers for quite some time
now since even before the infinity Saga
ended before Avengers endgame we
expected the Young Avengers to come in
Phase 4 and then phase four came and we
were introduced to a lot of potential
candidates for the roster of this new
Young Avengers team so fans were getting
ready they were bracing themselves to
get a Young Avengers project this could
be a Disney Plus show or this could be a
movie however then a Marvel executive
came out and stated we are not doing a
Young Avengers project and a lot of
people went what the heck how can you
not and this statement wasn't exactly
false but it wasn't exactly true as it
does look like we are indeed going to be
getting a Young Avengers project however
it just might not be called the Young
Avengers and they might not be all that
young however one of the members of this
so-called Young Avengers team is going
to be a variant of Kang comic book fans
know who I'm talking about and we'll
dive into that in this video and we have
some news from some insiders today
talking about the Young Avengers project
and what it is actually going to be so
for starters let's talk about how the
title might not actually be the Young
Avengers and some of the members of The
Young Avengers team aren't exactly going
to be so young take for example Cassie
Lang and Kate Bishop they're not super
super young not like Billy and Tommy in
one division they were young and if you
are wondering about the two of them yes
it does look like they are indeed coming
back and of course that will tie into
Agatha Covenant of chaos and the
upcoming Scarlet Witch projects which
we'll talk about so not all of them are
going to be insanely young and it does
look like some adult Avengers will be
involved in this Young Avengers project
but like I said the title is most likely
not going to be Young Avengers what
we've heard so far is the Children's
Crusade and in the comics the title is
simply Avengers The Children's Crusade
so when the Marvel executive said they
aren't making a Young Avengers project
he could have been quite literal as in
they are not making something titled the
Young Avengers they are making something
titled the Children's Crusade or The
Avengers The Children's Crusade because
according to The Insider my time to
shine hello who has an excellent track
record with Scoops she states the ending
of Agatha coven of chaos will be the
setup for the Children's Crusade she
also kind of gives us an update about
the release plan for it stating that
it's not going to come out until 2025 or
2026. but this update could tell us a
little bit about what the story of the
Children's Crusade is going to be about
as well as Agatha coven of chaos and
both of them should link together or at
least a part of Agatha coven of chaos
should linked together with the
Children's Crusade you see in the comics
the Children's Crusade is about Wanda's
son Wiccan or Billy as we've come to
know him from One Division and in the
comics Wiccan very much has powers
similar to his mothers he has reality
altering powers and in this specific
storyline his reality altering powers
are out of control so he seeks out his
mother the Scarlet Witch now this story
is really really interesting because it
has a lot of characters involved
including the Scarlet Witch and Dr Doom
as well as many other young Heroes now
of course the MCU doesn't always adapt
stories from the comics Page by Page
they don't tell the exact same story
they change it they just kind of take
the general idea for the story and make
it their own so perhaps the reality
altering powers of Wiccan aren't going
to be the main story for the Children's
Crusade however we have heard some
rumors about Agatha coven of chaos and
what the plot could be about and based
off of what we know Billy is indeed
returning haven't heard anything about
Tommy but Billy who is Wiccan should be
returning in Agatha coven of chaos now
right away I know everybody is thinking
the same thing how is that possible
Multiverse of Madness was literally
about Wanda trying to get her kids back
and at the end she didn't and some
people even think that she died at the
end of Multiverse Madness but we know
that she didn't she's got a solo movie a
true Solo movie eventually coming and
rumor has it that she's going to make a
cameo in Agatha coven of chaos which
makes sense because at the end of one
division she is the one who kind of
traps Agatha now according to the rumor
mill Agatha is going to be set free
because Wanda ended up destroying the
darkhold in Multiverse Madness and
apparently and I do air quotes here died
so this sets Agatha free and apparently
she is going to have a son which is
supposed to be some type of
Reincarnation of Wiccan now it's
important to keep in mind this is not
confirmed yet this is just a league
slash rumor however it does make a lot
of sense because we've actually had
several reports about Wiccan being a
part of Agatha coven of chaos whether or
not he's going to be Agatha's child or
Wanda's child that remains to be seen
but this could take a play from the
comics and have him have reality
altering powers and that could lead him
to seek out the Scarlet Witch who I'm
sure would love to have him since she
spent an entire movie killing a bunch of
people trying to get him back now here's
something really cool that could happen
in this series and then in the
Children's Crusade that happened in the
comics that would be absolutely wild if
it happened in the MCU this could
introduce or could include even more if
he's already introduced at this point in
time Dr Doom and possibly but probably
not Magneto you see in this story in the
comics Wanda is actually missing and
much like what is rumored to be the plot
of coven of Chaos in this story Wiccan
and speed are believed to be the
reincarnations of Wanda's children so
they seek her out however Magneto steps
up because Magneto at this point in time
is believed to be Wanda other and he
believes that it's time that his
grandkids know who he is so he helps
them try to find the Scarlet Witch and
eventually they believe that they find
her however it is revealed that the
Scarlet Witch that they thought they
found was actually a doom butt so Wiccan
ends up teleporting Magneto and the
Young Avengers to latvaria now when they
get there they find out that Wanda has
no powers and she's actually engaged to
Dr Doom but what's interesting and this
is how it could actually fit into the
MCU is that the Avengers and the X-Men
and the Young Avengers are basically all
fighting over Wanda deciding what to do
with her some believe that she should be
killed but some obviously do not think
that and that could very well be the
case for the MCU if you think about
everything that has recently happened
with Wanda the events of Wanda Vision
her holding a town hostage and then of
course her getting a hold of the dark
hold learning very dark magic and then
killing so many people she's probably
not looked too highly upon and we know
that she is going to be making a return
and it would make sense to have her
return for Secret Wars because she has
knowledge about the Multiverse and the
dark hold and let's just face it she is
probably the most powerful hero that we
have in the MCU at this point in time
they need her to fight Kang however we
can see how some Heroes will probably
say she's a villain she murdered a bunch
of people and we can't control her we
should kill her but then of course there
will be some people that say no she's
fine now the dark hold is destroyed plus
we need her powers and her strength to
fight King this could create a lot of
conflict but could be a very good story
and our Young Avengers film or the
Children's Crusade could be about this
this could involve the Scarlet Witch but
it is also rumored to involve like I
mentioned a variant of King who is Iron
lad now if you don't know who Iron lad
is he's really cool and he is a variant
of King he is Nathaniel Richards and he
was living the normal life that the
other variants of King have lived
however his future self stepped in when
a kid was bullying him in school this
event in the lives of the other kangs in
the past led to the school bully cutting
Nathaniel's throat which almost killed
him and almost bankrupted his parents
trying to treat it and make him better
again so Kang interferes he goes in the
past to meet his younger self he stops
the event from happening and then he
gives his younger self a suit of armor
and he shows his Nathaniel glimpses of
the future showing him that he is
destined to become king the Conqueror he
is destined to conquer now the Future
King did this in hopes that this would
kind of jump start his path earlier than
the Future self's Path so he was kind of
trying to give him a head start however
this ended up simply mortifying the
young Nathaniel Richards who did not
want to go down this path now this
Nathaniel Richards was actually an earth
6311 and in order to not become king the
Conqueror in order to escape his Destiny
he ends up using the armor that Kang
provided him to not only travel
throughout time but across Dimensions as
well and he ends up in a modern day
Earth in the 616 Universe he sought The
Avengers to look for help however the
Avengers Mansion was basically destroyed
he then looked for Tony Stark but found
it very hard to get in touch with him so
he ended up breaking in to start
Industries where he basically found a
vision bot he reprogrammed the armor for
himself and he became Iron lad he then
found other Young Avengers and they
formed the younger Avengers team
unfortunately him being in this universe
caused a lot of chaos to time and
eventually Kang came for him to try and
undo the Young Avengers eventually iron
lad realized that he would have to leave
the universe in order for that Universe
to be okay he ends up killing his future
self King the Conqueror and ends up
deciding to go back home however in his
own timeline he would go on to discover
that there are ways to travel throughout
time without affecting timelines and
this is probably going to be a pretty
big concept for Secret Wars for the
Multiverse Saga Multiverse of Madness Mr
Fantastic talked a lot about incursions
and how traveling to other universe is a
big No-No because it can cause
incursions however what if there was a
way to do it without causing incursions
the Avengers and the other heroes are
definitely going to need to know this
and since we are being introduced to a
lot of different versions of Kang it
would make sense that iron lad would
come from Another Universe to try and
help our Avengers team and it looks like
that might actually happen in the Young
Avengers project the Children's Crusade
and according to The Insider The Watcher
iron lad will indeed be in the
Children's Crusade project along with
hulkling who is rumored to be making an
appearance in secret Invasion however
that is not confirmed so we'll have to
wait and see on that however The
Avengers The Children's Crusade project
has the potential to be something pretty
dang cool and it sounds like pretty
important as well but hey let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below and please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf